the movie begins by providing historical
context explaining that in the late
1800s there was a Conference held to
divide up the African Congo Basin during
this event King Leopold II of Belgium
seized control of the Region's valuable
minerals leading to large profits for
his Nation however after 5 years the
resources began to run dry acre massive
debts for the state to address this
issue Leopold sent Captain Leon ROM to
secure precious diamonds of opar we then
see Leon leading a group of armed men
into the Congo region after a long walk
they come across a large rock formation
that resembles a human face just then
they hear some sound coming from the fog
prompting them to take their position
when a spear is thrown towards them
lon's men open fire killing dozens of
African tribesmen as they walk forward
into the fog they discover a large
number of tribesmen surrounding them
from above the Rocks following this all
the men are killed by The Warriors
leaving only Leon at last the tribe
leader Chief mabonga shows up and
proposes a deal to Leon diamonds in
exchange for a particular person George
of the Jungle H Tarzan the scene then
cuts to England where the prime minister
speaks to a guy named John Clayton III
Earl of greystoke he is invited by King
Leopold to head an expedition to Bulma
Congo as he's considered to be a real
Tarzan man however John politely
declines the invitation and walks away
an American Envoy named George
Washington Williams follows him outside
and tries to persuade him to consider
otherwise he explains that Leopold is
defaulting on his loans and a visit from
greystoke would secure Britain's
influence in the Congo furthermore
George reveals his suspicions that
Leopold is enslaving people and finally
persuades Jon to go to the Congo in
order to discover the truth following
this we see a flashback of decades
earlier when Jon's parents survived a
shipwreck but got stranded in the
African jungle Jon's father kept himself
and his pregnant wife hidden in a
treehouse sadly she died after giving
birth to John this origin story just
doesn't slap as hard without Phil
Collins a few days later Jon's father
was also attacked and killed by a band
of gorillas the Little Jon was then
adopted by the mangani a race of Apes
when he grew up John left Africa for
grey Stoke estate in Britain with his
American Wife Jane and now he has
embraced a new life as a wealthy
nobleman back in the present johon goes
to his wife who is in the midst of
conducting a class with a group of
children later he privately informs her
about the Expedition trip which fills
her with excitement John initially tries
to forbid her from accompanying him as
it is not safe however he eventually
relents when she insists she seen those
abs she knows he's a monkey man the very
next day John Jane and George set off on
their Journey to the Congo along the way
they come across a group of lions and
Jon interacts with them affectionately
Jane then tells George that Jon has
known these Lions since they were Cubs
after a while they arrive at Bulma where
they are warmly welcomed by the Kuba
Village the same place where JN and Jane
spent their youth it turns out that
Jane's father used to teach English here
the villagers appear to be delighted by
their arrival Jane also reunites with
her childhood friend wasimo later that
night they gather around a bond fire and
Jane shares Jon's past with George she
recounts how Jon adapted to life in the
forest and became strong according to
Jane John's ape mother kala loved him as
her own whereas his ape brother akot
treated him with kindness and respect
she also reveals how odd their first
encounter in the forest was Legend has
it he threw Pooh at her elsewhere Leon
and his men find out John's whereabouts
and take a steamship towards their
location they attack the Kuba Village in
the middle of the night hold the chief
at gunpoint and instruct him to kneel
however the ladder refuses claiming that
the chief never kneels down as a result
leyon mercilessly shoots him to death
Jon fights some of Lyon's men but he is
ultimately captured by the overwhelming
number of guards after being tied up he
is taken to their steamship along with
some more villagers including Jane and
wasimo before reaching the ship George
intervenes by opening fire towards the
enemies he somehow manages to Rescue Jon
but Lon and his men sail away with Jane
and the captive villagers in the morning
Jon is ashamed of the destruction caused
by those who were actually targeting him
believing that the bad guys are on route
to bulma's Mountain Jon along with
several villagers devises a shortcut
route that will get them there before
Lyon's ship our hero then decides to
become his Tarzan Persona once more here
comes the loin cloth after this the
group wastes no time and makes their way
towards the forest during this George
struggles to keep Pace with the new gang
upon arriving at a cliff George asks Jon
about how he's planning to catch the
moving train to which Jon replies
gravity impressive oneliner for a monkey
then he and his comrades jump off the
cliff George hesitates but he has no
other choice but to follow suit
meanwhile on the steam ship Jane tells
Leon that they are in the Congo by Royal
invitation much to her surprise Leon
reveals that he was the one who
orchestrated the invitation so that he
can capture Tarzan and deliver him to
mabonga later on Jane is released from
her restraints and is taken to Lyon's
quarters for dinner on the way she
passes by wasimo who is caged above the
water a guard threatens to drown him if
she tries anything stupid during this
meal Leon shares his wish to become a
governor general by Saving his King from
bankruptcy back in the forest Jon
carries George on his back and the team
swings from Vines at high speed they
land onto the move moving train which is
transporting Belgian soldiers and
enslaved congales this only fuels Jon
with rage and as a result he takes down
the soldiers just then the solders
leader walks in but Jon kicks him off
the train in seconds a short while later
an engineer is brought to them who
swears that he is only building a bridge
for Lyon's Army confused Jon asks for
more details in response the engineer
tells him about Lyon's plan to take over
the Congo sanctioned by Leopold
according to him Leon is building forts
across the region linked by Railways and
River travel they are expecting an army
of 20,000 mercenaries who will all be
arriving soon with Leopold bankrupt Leon
needs the diamonds of opar to pay for
the Army the next day Jon and George
plan their next moves upon Gathering the
necessary proof to expose Leopold Jon
and George leave the proof with the
kubba Warriors asking him to deliver it
to Bulma the two of them then set off on
foot continuing their journey through m
G territory on their way George wonders
if Jon can actually talk to the animals
shortly after he gets a chance to see it
happen a bunch of ostriches pass by them
and one of them is apparently telling
George to stay clear scars guards just
staring at the green screen saying I'm
talking to what after some time they
arrive at mangani Region where they are
confronted by a group of gorillas John
then explains how things will work he
says that aot who was once his brother
now considers him as a deserter he asks
George not to intervene under any
circumstances following this a fierce
battle ensues between Jon and auts with
auts swiftly overpowering him within
minutes when he approaches George Jon
instructs him to kneel down as George
complies akut and the other gorillas
depart letting them live but now Jon
sustains a painful bite on his back so
George has to use ants for stitching up
the wound the duo then decides to rest
in the same area for a while while
sitting by the fire George confides in
Jon about his past disclosing that he
was once a mercenary himself he admits
to having engaged in a lot of stuff that
he's not proud of and deep down he fears
he might be no different than those
belgians they make good chocolate though
so it's okay the following morning on
the steamship Jane shouts something to
wasimo in his native language this
infuriates the guards prompting them to
drop the cage into the water fortunately
Jane jumps into the water as well and
breaks wasimo out they swim to the shore
and Escape into the jungle Jane
instructs was simu to rally the other
tribesmen as she knows that Lyon's men
will pursue her a short time later she
enters the mongani region where she
encounters a group of gorillas she
promptly kneels and Bows in submission
soon after Leon arrives with his men
Leon cautiously approaches Jane and asks
her to come with her she agrees on the
condition that they won't hurt the Apes
but as they slowly walk backwards Leon's
men open fire killing several gorillas
Jon can hear the gunshots and Jane's
screaming from a far as a result he
immediately swings all the way there
arriving just in time to save his ape
brother from a Belgian bullet amid the
battle Leon and his inner circle managed
to flee still taking Jane as their
hostage they make their way to mbonga's
tribe on the other hand George is
wandering around the forest trying to
find Jon the scene then shifts to a
flashback that explains why mabanga is
so determined to capture Tarzan years
ago manga's son unknowingly killed Jon's
Foster mother kala while hunting in the
mongani territory in retaliation Jon
brutally killed mabanga son as Jon held
a dying kala in his arms mabanga people
brought his son's body back in the
present Jon follows Leon and his men
into manga's territory where he is
greeted by the entire tribe he tries to
sort things out with mabanga but the
latter isn't ready to hear anything a
one-on-one confrontation that ensues
between Jon and mabanga soon after Jon
gains the upper hand holding mabanga at
knife point prompting the entire tribe
to encircle him however Jon is not alone
as a cot shows up with several gorillas
behind him moments later George also
arrives and enlightens mabonga about
Lyon's Sinister plan he asserts that
Lyon is their actual enemy and not JN as
Leon intends to wipe out manga's entire
tribe in order to capture the land this
Revelation convinces mabanga who then
takes a step back on the other hand Leon
transports Jane and the Diamonds to
Bulma where the mercenary Army
approaches the shoreline Jon and George
also reach the scene and realize that
they cannot defeat the overwhelming
number of mercenaries head on as a
result JN comes up with an idea he sends
a stampede of wde Beast through the town
overrunning Leon's men and demolishing
the valley completely amidst this
commotion Kuba Warriors also arrive by
train and free their captive villagers
sensing the imminent danger Leon orders
the diamonds be shipped into the steam
ship he also tries has to drag Jane
along with him but it's already too late
so he ends up leaving her meanwhile Jon
runs with the Stampede jumps a top of
Buffalo and swings through the harbor
attacking some armed men scars guard
still in front of the green screen
saying I'm doing what he soon rescues
Jane before pursuing Lyon Lyon is
already on his steamship preparing to
deliver the diamonds to his corrupt
financier Mr fr along with the
mercenaries in the meantime George comes
across a vintage machine gun which he
uses to destroy the steam ship causing
it to start sinking just then Jon climbs
up the sinking vessel to confront Leon
in their intense struggle Leon chokes
Jon with his rosary beads sure that's
what they are and ties him to the ship
despite this Jon Fights Back by trapping
Leon between his legs and applying
pressure until the beads snap from his
neck he then uses a sound of a maen call
to summon crocodiles and leaves Leon to
their Mercy Jon escapes the ship just
before it explod exps he then returns
back to his wife and kisses her as the
villagers all cheer damn they're so hot
oh my
God hot in the aftermath of these events
George returns to London and presents an
open letter to the Prime Minister
exposing the insl
avementoroh44060 videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching